how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and of course
all things mcu and today we got some
pretty big news
not only a huge plot point for the
eternals revealed and the main villain
for the eternals revealed as well
but from these reveals it does seem like
namor is going to be in the eternals in
some way
shape or form with his city of atlantis
definitely being in the movie somehow
and it seems like with the reveal of
this villain and the villain's backstory
in the comics we have a pretty good idea
of how neymar and atlantis will be a
part of the eternals so i'm going to
break down this new villain
who he is what his powers are and what
his story is
how he'll affect the movie and how we
basically know what athena's
big secret is and how namor and atlantis
will tie into the film
if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
cyclops funko pop i'm picking a winner
on monday
so as sad as it is unfortunately if the
pandemic never happened we'd be getting
the eternals
next month it was originally scheduled
for release in theaters on november 6th
of 2020. but of course everything has
been shuffled around now including the
order of the movies and tv shows coming
out in marvel's phase 4.
now the eternals has been pushed back a
year now coming out on november 5th of
2021
however it seems like all of the product
including
toys has been long completed and when
you have a movie get pushed back
almost a year these toys leak and that's
exactly what happened with the eternals
last night a picture of a toy of the
main villain for the eternals got leaked
so if you are trying to avoid any and
all spoilers for the eternals movie now
is your chance to click away
if you are still with me the official
villain of the eternals is going to be
crow now i don't really expect many
people to know who this is the eternals
weren't that popular of comics and crow
is definitely an eternal's villain but
what's interesting here
is that we're essentially dealing with
another thanos
he's very very similar to the mad titan
crow has existed for over 25 000 years
he was one of the first
deviants created on earth by the
celestials now the celestials created
the eternals and the deviants
while the eternals are very attractive
and nearly immortal peacekeepers the
deviants are pretty much the opposite
although they do live for very long
periods of time but the deviants and the
eternals have gone to war with each
other for thousands and thousands of
years and
crow has led the deviant army against
the eternals
now there's some really important
backstory that you need to know about
crow before we get into athena's big
secret and before we get into neymor and
atlantis
as i mentioned before crow is not that
different than thanos now thanos was
born of two
eternals but he inherited the deviant
gene but much like
thanos crow is practically
indestructible and if he does manage to
actually get hurt he can heal himself on
command all he has to do is think about
healing himself and it happens
but another thing that makes crow
extremely dangerous is he can actually
shapeshift again just by thinking about
it he can warp the tissue on his body
and he can even alter his skeleton
and skull in minor ways he's actually
disguised himself as the devil plenty of
times in marvel comics
even growing horns out of his head now
this is very useful for him because as i
said he's immortal crow has figured out
a way to never die
at least not from old age or disease now
the other deviants don't have this power
and he keeps his power a secret from
them so every thousand years or so he'll
shapeshift to look like somebody
different and just claims that he's an
ancestor from crow and that's why he
looks like him crow has also been the
leader
and king of the deviant so as far as a
villain goes for the eternals they've
picked a pretty good one but as far as
the character goes it's more than just
his strength and abilities that make him
a good villain
it's also his connection with athena now
some of you may recall that for about a
year now there's been a big rumor going
around that athena
angelina jolie's character in the
eternals is going to have a
huge secret in the movie and it looks
like we just figured it out because in
the comics her
and crow are actually in a relationship
together now of course this
is forbidden an eternal and a deviant
being together
so they keep it a secret but this goes
on for thousands and thousands of years
off and on
and not to mention and this is the
really big part that could have a huge
impact on the mcu they have kids
together they actually have twins
donald and deborah now the twins only
pop up in the comics a few times they're
not really
that important especially because thena
when she finds out that she's pregnant
transfers the kids into a human and that
woman then has the kids
however people end up finding out about
their children and the two of them go on
the run
ultimately the eternals would leave
thena alone and allow her to go on the
run with crow but
the deviants still chase after crow now
i've done at least a couple of videos
theorizing about thena's big secret and
one of those theories that i have
is that her son could actually be thanos
because let's face it marvel studios as
they should doesn't follow the exact
stories of the comics
if they did we'd know everything that
was going to happen and there is a
possibility that they could do
a little bit of retconning here to make
thanos then a son
because remember it's already been
confirmed that the eternals movie is
going to take place over a span
of 20 000 plus years so we'll see things
happen from before avengers in game and
after avengers in game now in avengers
infinity war they did confirm that
thanos's father
is alars and that is who his father is
in the comics
now they could find a way around this
since crow is a shapeshifter he could
have transformed himself
into an eternal looking person and from
there he could call himself alars now in
the comics thanos's mother is suicide
however we haven't heard mention of her
in the mcu yet so that could easily be
retconned again just a theory but let me
know if you would like to see this would
you like thanos to be
the son of theena let me know in the
comments down below and now to talk
about the connection with atlantis and
neymar now we've already had a couple of
reports concerning the eternals and
atlantis
some reports simply state that atlantis
is going to be in the internals in some
way shape or form and the other says
that we're actually going to see
the sinking of atlantis happen because
remember we will be exploring
ancient times like ancient egypt ancient
greece in the eternals film
and it looks like we're going to be
seeing one huge event that happened in
marvel comics called the great
cataclysm now the great cataclysm sunk
atlantis and it also sunk
lumeria lumeria was a city that the
deviants ran
and lived in now this event is tied with
the celestials and it said that the
celestials observed how the eternals had
ignored
baseline humanity while the deviants
enslaved humanity and in their fury
caused this destruction to happen
now crowe since he's immortal and has
been alive for about 25 000 years
he actually witnessed this happen way
back in time
so if we consider the fact that we've
had reports that we're going to see
atlantis and the eternals and we're
actually going to see
the sinking of atlantis and if we take
into account the fact that the eternals
is going to take place
over 20 000 years of marvel cinematic
universe timeline
from ancient greece and egypt to all the
way after the events of avengers in-game
and if you consider the fact that crow
has lived throughout that
entire time and we're probably going to
be following him and his story
it makes sense that we'll see atlantis
and possibly namor or his father
in the eternals as we discover crow's
origin i should also add that we could
be seeing some pretty big godzilla type
monsters in the eternals as well
in the comics there's something called
monster island which holds
deviant mutates these are huge giant
creatures
that crow at one point in time sets free
he releases tricephalous
giganto and gigantis from the island
that is near japan
so i think as far as a villain goes for
the eternals they picked a really good
one
one that is incredibly powerful and
rules over the deviants and one who has
a connection with one of the strongest
eternals
and hopefully there's a little bit more
of a secret to the story of who their
kid
or kids may be but let me know what you
think about this villain choice for the
eternals and who do you think
is going to be the child of athena and
crow in the mcu
let me know all your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the marvel videos for
lab updates you can follow me on twitter
and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof